okay i need to hear your take on this
one
buzzfeed news reports in a new interview
with the incredible andrew garfield he
is like a walking jawline he has goals
goals
well he admitted in a very he's very
uncomfortable he said when one of his
friends makes a bad movie right he says
it doesn't happen often but when it does
it's hard to know what to say because
you run into them and you didn't love
their movies and so what he says he
tells him is well you really did that
i think it's so funny
because if you had a friend not maybe
make a movie but do something that
wasn't like a hundred and like what do
you say in the i'm like look at you
yeah what do you do rossi well i have a
rule i call it um it's a short haircut
or tattoo rule where like it's too late
for me to do anything like my friend has
a really short terrible haircut or got a
tattoo that's terrible there's nothing i
can do to fix it so i just say
well
are you happy do you love it oh
but if you ask me first should i get
this haircut should i get this tattoo i
will give you the truth smart smart bros
i like it
you can steal it use it short haircut
tattoo
hey um we got to talk about one of your
favorites jose andres this incredible
chef you all know who this is well his
group
world central kitchen
they've been doing amazing work on the
ground in ukraine feeding people since
the very start of the war and now people
reports their sandwich line uh in levive
is pumping out 10 000 sandwiches a day
think about that
do the math two slices of bread that's
twenty thousand slices of bread and
world central kitchen has served over
four million meals to ukrainians so far
and to support their incredible work we
encourage you if you can go to our
website for more information but we just
wanted to shout out that amazing work
that
[Applause]
i am going to make a 500 000 donation to
world central kitchen and i am hoping
that if somebody can help me match it
that we can raise a million dollars oh
my god
wow
wow
i am in awe of what he is doing and
please let's raise money because he is
working in ukraine but he is working
everywhere he is front and center he
does not waste time he shows up i want
to do everything i can to support him
wow drew that's so go to our website a
dollar anything it will all make a
difference
[Music]